sorry wait they'll miss that's Latin for
hello world this is Jessica from
compchomp we're borrowing her right now
she's off wondering if AI is breeding
humans the code behind matchmaking apps
and other fun stuff but native land
compchomp are teaming up and heading to
youtube to film a short series about the
amazing ways code and language overlap
and get mixed together the history of
computer translation why passwords
aren't real words anymore she has some
cool things to show us we're also giving
her a chance to share a personal note
about being a female programmer so
please enjoy these extra linguistic
insights from our visiting coder before
we get back to our regular programming
it'll be hard work and I'm grateful to
have her here we hope you'll catch the
videos particularly if you're a fan of
computational linguistics or programming
languages see you in just a couple
Friday's until then stay tuned and
subscribe for language